if I were the leader of the country I
probably wouldn't do anything very much
different from anyone else no matter
what I believe
and the reason is I would be under such
tight constraints from real objective
power that I just wouldn't have any
leeway there's good reasons for but so
let me instead of going into that I go
into that if you like but instead of
doing that let me answer your first
question what if the Bologna take your
other way of formulating what do I think
we ought to do well I think there's some
pretty obvious answers both in the
Middle East and in at least there's a
general framework for obvious answers in
the Middle East and in Central America
in the Middle East there's been a very
broad international consensus on a
political settlement of the arab-israeli
conflict then there has been for many
many years that consensus for example
was expressed in a resolution that came
to the UN Security Council in January
1976 that's 13 years ago it called for a
two-state settlement establishment of a
Palestinian state in the West Bank and
the Gaza Strip a settlement on the
internationally recognized borders
namely the pre June in the 1967 borders
and then it just repeated the wording of
UN 242 the main UN document with
guarantees for the independence and
territorial integrity of security of
every state in the region and it's right
to live in peace and security within
recognized boundaries and then it went
on to discuss some modalities you know
for achieving this end that's the basic
framework of the international consensus
well that particular resolution was
vetoed by the United States Israel
refused to attend the session the
resolution was initiated by the three
major Arab states Syria Jordan and Egypt
the three confrontation States it was
supported by the PLO in fact it was
openly supported by the PLO according to
the Israeli delegate who's now the
president of Israel it was in fact
prepared by the PLO notice that that is
worth noting this because that means
that already 13 years ago
Arafat had gone exactly as far as he did
in that famous press conference on
December 14th which was alleged by the
media
changed everything nothing changed he
just repeated the same position he'd
been saying for the last 13 years the
reasons why the United States changed
its position but that's different this
was supported by the Soviet Union it was
supported by most of Europe it was
supported by most of the aligned
non-aligned countries in fact virtually
by the entire world that's why the
United States had to veto it alone
well that's you could argue about
details but something like that is a
probably the only plausible least
interim settlement if you wanted to
pursue it seriously you'd have to talk
about economic relations of a federal
nature between the two states and all
sorts of other things and modalities to
secure it and so on and so forth but
that general idea has been a very broad
international consensus for years the
United States is alone virtually decide
from Israel and opposing it I mean not
totally alone like it's posed by Qaddafi
there are rejectionists aside from the
united states part there's marginal
groups around the world like Khomeini
you know the Afghan rebels I mean a few
other groups that oppose it but
primarily it's opposed by the United
States that's why it doesn't get
anywhere now that has disappeared from
history on the assumptions of the
propaganda model that's not part of the
peace process why because the United
States was opposed to it and it's a
logical impossibility that the United
States should be opposed to the peace
process so therefore that's going from
history when the United when the New
York Times or any scholarly monograph
for that matter reviews the peace
process they don't include this because
this is not part of the peace process
well that's only one example there are
many others and I think that's a general
framework for settlement as far as
Central America is concerned I think
it's pretty obvious what ought to happen
generally speaking I mean the United
States has carried out major crimes in
Central America really major crimes in
the night I mean first of all our whole
history looked Central America's want to
look miserable areas of the world and
it's an area where US influence has been
enormous for a century well at once that
tells you something you know I mean have
to think very hard to figure out what
that means and it's four reasons there
are reasons for it you look into the
details you can find out reasons for it
even the so-called constructive programs
were actually lethal like take the
alliance for progress you know most of
our of the lot of what happened in
Central America is just because we
impose dictators and gangsters and
terrorists and so on if they ever try to
get independent as in Guatemala but
every once in a while there's something
called a constructive program the
Alliance for Progress is the famous case
well you know the Alliance for Progress
was like a plague for the worst plague
that hit Central America until the
Reagan administration that's killer
isn't a category by themselves the
Alliance for Progress first of all was a
completely cynical operation I mean the
Alliance before progress was not
instituted by the Kennedy administration
because they suddenly discovered that
there are poor people in Central America
and they knew that all along it was
initiated because they were afraid that
the poor people in Central America were
going to follow the Cuban model now that
means it began as a purely cynical
operation okay and that's show the
Alliance for Progress was designed to
impose on Latin America altogether in
fact an agro-export model they're
supposed to shift production from
subsistence crops to export for the
benefit of US agribusiness in the
American market well as consequences for
example it means that farmers in Central
America are expected not to produce rice
and beans for them people locally to eat
but asparagus and broccoli and flowers
for yuppie markets in the United States
well for one thing that means not going
to eat so I got to import food which
they import from us at high costs which
is good for American agriculture
subsidized usually by the American
taxpayer now subsidized by them second
and it also means that and that food is
not going to be equally distributed it's
going to be distributed to the rich
furthermore the production is going to
be by the rich because it takes capital
inputs to produce the fancy fruits for
the American market so there's going to
be landless peasants furthermore they're
going to produce beef and in fact every
latin-american Trull American country
beef production moved up rapidly under
the alliance for progress while beef
consumption redo
and the reason is that ranchers moved in
often with North American connections
drove peasants off their land turned it
into grazing lands so they could send
beef to North American markets for
hamburgers great for Agrabah for
American agribusiness and for pesticide
and fertilizer manufacturers and for the
rich in Central America but not very
good for the people now you take a look
at you look to your favorite economics
book or Latin American Studies book and
they'll tell you that the Alliance for
Progress created an economic miracle
well you know from a certain point of
view it did a gross national product
went up all through Central America so
did malnutrition no and the reason is
obvious you drive people off the land up
into the hills and you take over their
land and you produce beef for export and
fancy crops it's good for the gross
national product just means the people
starve you know in fact the crisis of
the 1980s is largely caused by that
plague well let's just take the 1980s
during the 1980s the Reagan
administration is responsible for
roughly 200,000 people slaughtered and
that doesn't mean just killed you know
that means tortured and mutilated and
raped
I mean Pol Pot style tortured that's
pretty serious business hundreds of
thousands five millions of refugees
large areas of the country destroyed all
of this in an effort to block social
reform in all three major countries
where we were involved in Honduras and
El Salvador in Nicaragua now that's
serious what should we do well the first
the first thing we should do is stop
torturing them the second thing we
should do is pay reparations because we
own and after that maybe there's some
hope that they could reconstruct from
the damage we've done to them I think
that's what we ought to do try to find
anybody suggesting that in the
mainstream however you can't express
this view not because it's false but
because it's true and if you look into
it you'll find that it's true I think
now how what should we do I mean let's
go back well we should do we are free to
act
plenty of things that we can do one
thing we can just provide aid ourselves
you'll have to wait for the state to
order you to provide aid they need it
badly
I mean Nicaragua was reeling the
hurricane last October was the final
blow they're gonna have mass starvation
there now the government of course is
delighted the US government the inland
cinema penny because they want them to
suffer as much as possible but American
citizens are much more independent and
in fact they've raised a lot of money
for example there's one small Jesuit
center in North Carolina or Virginia or
somewhere thee quest for peace it's
called the Quixote a center a little I
think they they have three staff members
or something they've raised millions of
dollars from people in the United States
who are able to think for themselves who
weren't just slaves of power and those
are things that can be done you can help
people survive and you can have to all
put pressure on on Congress on the media
to do something about this a lot of ways
of doing that ways all sorts of ways
ranging from civil disobedience to
writing letters to the editor to you
know a mass popular organization you
know they're not gonna put you in jail
for it in that sense a very free country
which means if you don't do it you have
a lot more responsibility than if you
don't do it in a place where you are
afraid that you're gonna be repressed so
there's no shortage of things to do it's
just a matter of willingness to do them
and the willingness to do them begins
with the willingness to recognize
reality that's the hardest part I think
once you recognize reality you won't
have any more questions about what to do
cuz too obvious so the first thing to do
is to recognize the reality and it takes
a little work but once you recognize it
I think it's obvious what to do